we are continuing
our topic of the visiting visitation
of the sick the ill and also
the way that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
would follow the geneza the way that he
would
perform janazah et cetera
this is taken from the book
provisions for the hereafter for the
great appointment taken from
the traditions and the ways of
the best of mankind authored by shem
siddin
even jose
last week we spoke about some of the
etiquettes with regards to
visiting the ill and how the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would visit
the ill
and some of the intentions behind
visitation
of those who are sick it should be
mentioned that visitation of the ill
is what the scholars refer to as farduki
faya
this is an obligation which
is obligatory upon all of the community
but only a gr a group is required
from amongst the community to perform
this act
a then for example if there is a
community of muslims
a then is obligatory upon all of them
but only one person makes the adhan on
behalf of the rest
likewise is the issue of geneza and
returning assalaam somebody comes in and
says assalamu alaikum everyone who hears
him
is obliged to reply but if one alone
replies that's enough on behalf of the
rest
this is what is referred to as kifaya
there is there's two types of
obligations with regards to community
the first is meaning every single person
is responsible to perform the act like
for example prayer
nobody can pray on behalf of someone
else
so every single person of amongst the
community is required to pray for him or
herself
whereas for example
which is an obligation upon the entirety
of the community
but one person or a group
may suffice and represent
the entirety of the community in that
act in that obligation
such as a then such as visiting the sick
such as
following the geneza right or
bathing the body or burial etc
all of these things are considered for
kefaya
so we spoke about some of the etiquettes
and it should be mentioned that
visitation of the ill is one of the
greater
one of the greater and most rewarding
acts a person can perform with regards
to communicative
acts of worship if a person goes to
visit
someone who is ill for the sake of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
mentions
that this person's path is a path of
paradise on his way there
and a path of paradise on his return
and there is a narration in which the
prophet sallallahu alaihi was
mentioned that allah subhanahu wa will
say on the day of resurrection
to an individual who failed to visit his
ill brother or sister
abdi my servant
i fell ill and you did not
come to visit me and so the servant will
reply how can i visit you when you are
and he will say my servant so and so had
fell
ill in your presence or in your time
and you knew of it and you did not visit
him
if you had visited him when he was ill
then you would have found me there with
him
so allah subhanahu wa is with the ill
those who are ill and patient in their
illness
and when a person goes to visit this
individual
allah is with him as well
he says regarding the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sunnah in visiting the
ill
min
he says that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam never designated any
particular day
of the week or month or year or any
particular
time of day to visit someone who is ill
rather any time to visit a person who is
ill
any day is sufficient
what this means is that according to the
customs of the people
you're not going to go visit someone
who's ill at three in the morning
or two in the morning that's not what's
intended
what's intended is it it's regard
it regards the appropriate time
and place and customs of the person that
you're going to
visit so in some
customs it's perfectly
okay to go visit someone after isha and
other places
under other demographics or demographics
or other
areas or communities it is
considered to be rude to visit someone
after a certain time of
of the day or night likewise with
regards to
how long a person stays and so forth
this is all
goes back to what's appropriate for the
time and place and the person that is
being visited
he says
[Silence]
was narrated to have visited
the ill in his time
who were suffering from ailments such as
pink eye or infection in the eyes
which is known as and others
these are contagious but they're only
contagious if you touch them
contrary to contagions which are
respiratory for instance if a person
has
some kind of virus that is respiratory
if you visit this person it may be to
your own detriment
if a person is going to be in danger
then a person should not visit
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam has mentioned
he mentioned to avoid people
with certain types of illnesses
just as you would avoid a ferocious lion
why is that because
if a person is going to put himself in a
situation where it is deadly
or it is absolutely detrimental to his
or her health
something that is contagious something
that will be of detriment to his family
or to his community
then this is an exception and
alhamdulillah in our time we have ways
to
visit people without actually going in
person
if they are suffering from something
that is contagious
but something that is contagious but not
but but it can be contained so
for example infection of the eyes that
used to occur in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
which is referred to here as a ramadan
this is something that is only
infectious if you touch the person
the person's infection and touch touch
your own eyes
but if you're just merely in the room
with a person and you don't
have any physical contact with him this
will not
affect you so i think this is pretty
logical
and pretty straightforward
obviously if you're going to put
yourself at risk for getting ill
along with the person who is ill then
this doesn't
this doesn't benefit any of the parties
he mentioned that sometimes the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would place his hand
on the forehead of the ailing
and then he would wipe over his chest
and his stomach
and say allah oh allah please cure this
person
and sometimes he would wipe over
his own face alaihis
was of course this is
as long as it's not something that is
contagious or detrimental to a person's
health
and if he would see a person who is in a
state of
chronic
you know illness where there is
the person is going to die they're
essentially on their deathbed
he would say
to allah we belong into he we are
returning
this is what we are to say when we are
faced with any calamity
especially the calamity of death allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said
for a s
anytime you are afflicted with any type
of calamity
especially the calamity of death
he says
[Silence]
he mentions here that the prophet
salallahu
when he would his tradition and his way
with dealing with a person who has
passed away
is the best of traditions that he
salallahu alaihi wasallam would visit a
person before he dies
and upon a person's death he would
seek forgiveness on behalf of this
individual
with allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and ask
that allah keep this person
keep this person firm in belief
on his deathbed and when he is asked
in the grave he would as well prepare
the deceased the best of preparations of
bathing
and perfume and so forth and shrouding
and he salallahu alaihi wasallam would
then
stand in prayer to allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala praising allah and glorifying
allah and seeking forgiveness on behalf
of the deceased
as well as following the geneza all the
way till
the completion of the burial
and after the burial the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam would often
stand there at the grave with his
companions
seeking and making dua
with allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
this wouldn't be the end he would as
well go out of his way to visit
the graveyards and the muslim cemeteries
as well
and convey assalam to the deceased and
make dua for
the people who are buried and have
passed away
at the graveyard so
when a person goes to visit
the graveyard the cemetery there's no
particular day
or time when a person should go to visit
a person may visit at any time or day
which is appropriate in that community
sometimes people only go to the
graveyard on naid
graveyard in the middle of shaban
or the only go to the graveyard in
ramadan
or they only go to the graveyard on
jummah
all of this is not necessarily correct
rather
visiting the grave is any time just like
visiting the ill
so the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
made it an important habit
of his and a tradition of his ummah
that the person amongst the muslim
community who is
ailing with anything that the people are
with him
with this individual
from the beginning of their calamity
until the end of it
this is something that's really
important we have
people that we've become very
disconnected from each other
so we have people that are ailing
and have serious problems let's say a
person
has a child who passes away or has some
kind of major calamity
a lot of times they get a lot of support
at the very beginning of this calamity
and then everybody moves on with his or
her life
and forgets about the person and his
troubles
but this is this can articulate
to the person a lack of concern
and it can be misunderstood as a lack of
concern
and it also can cause a lot of
loneliness
i know of situations where people have
lost their children some
some of them have lost all of their
children at once
in one incident and at the very
beginning when the
issue first happens and the crisis first
occurs people are
there with the person for support but
after
a couple of weeks or a month goes by
everybody completely forgets about the
issue
entirely and there's no follow-through
there's no visitation
there's no call there's no anything as
if the world just moves on and
essentially the world would have to move
on but
the idea that we would
that we would forget about anyone's
problem and that we would not notice
a person suffering amongst us this is
something which is
unacceptable the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
would always look to his companions
see any of them that was missing ask
about him
inquire about any of the missing so much
so that
even in the battle of tabuk
which was one of the greatest
times that all of the companions had
to leave with the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam to tabuk
they were in the thousands the army was
in the thousands
and if anybody was not present you would
just assume that they were somewhere
else in the calvary because
the caravan was so large
and so even under these circumstances
even that there were so many companions
with him
he still was able to ask about
companions that were not present
and inquire about them
as is mentioned in the narration of
khabib and malik
very well-known narration in bukhari a
muslim this
tells us that he had a keen eye and
would always notice
any of his companions that were missing
any of them that were not present
someone is not there for prayer someone
is not there for
battle someone is not there for jummah
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would inquire about the person
would go out of his way to visit the
person even if the person was a muslim
and he would try to
comfort the person as best as he can
and this is something that is very
important and
is somewhat lacking amongst the
general
population when something first happens
people are there and then it becomes
very very lonely after that
there has to be a level of
follow-through we see that the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was would follow through
with
a person who is ailing a person who
is ill from the very beginning of the
illness
all the way until the person is in the
graveyard and still it would not
end there he would still visit the
graveyard
from time to time and continue to visit
those whom he buried
when a person first would fall ill the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would go to visit the person he would
remind the person
of the hereafter he would
remind the person to make a will
if he has not already made a will he
would remind the person
to repent to allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
sincere repentance
and he also commanded sallallahu
alaihi wasallam that whoever goes to
visit someone who
is on his deathbed that he command him
to say
so when you go to visit someone who is
ill
there is different types of illness
sometimes a person is
ill to wear it's a minor illness they
broke their leg they
are sick with something they are down
with the flu whatever something that
they're going to be
okay after they're going to
survive most likely in this case you're
not going to go to the person
and
start to make them think they're going
to die
and cause them to panic and have a lot
of anxiety
that's not what's intended but if you do
go to a person who is
clearly on his deathbed a lot of times
people don't want to tell the person
what's really wrong the real
complications because
this might scare the person but there
comes a time
when fear is
something that is necessary and there
comes a time when
we have to prepare
each other and prepare the person
for his or her departure from this world
and so he commanded that if a person is
dying
that we command him to say la
those who are dying amongst you remind
them to say that
and in the narration of in jebel in a
sunnah
the prophet sallallahu alaihi was said
whoever's final words of this world
will enter paradise surely
this is something that we remind people
to say
if they are on their deathbed
likewise recitation of the quran this is
something that's very good for a person
who is on his deathbed
it doesn't have to be any particular
chapter of the quran
any chapter will suffice but
it is preferred that it be chapters of
the quran
that will instill
hope in the person and cause the person
to
be hopeful and
willing to meet allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said in the narration of jabber
none of you is to pass away except that
he is thinking
good thoughts and making a good estimate
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
there is a narration in jamaica
[Silence]
there is a narration in german in which
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
says or was narrated to have said
recite surat yasin upon your dying
people have misunderstood this narration
this narration is not
an authentic narration and so
as we mentioned any verses of the quran
to recite
as a reminder to the person who is
passing away
will suffice but the best of
verses and narrations to mention to a
person who is on his deathbed
are narrations and verses of the quran
which will
instill hope in the person and good
thoughts about allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and sincere repentance right
[Silence]
and so one of the
chapters of the quran because surat
yasin has a lot of
good verses in it that are filled with
hope and beauty and instill a sense of
hope
and comfort in a person who is going
through calamity
but it's not meant
this narration doesn't mean as some
people have misunderstood it
to be recited when a person
is dead already and they're in their
grave people will stand at the grave
after the burial or during the burial
and recite surat yasin this is incorrect
and a misunderstanding of a of a weak
narration
what's intended is that a person recite
suratiya seen to a person who can listen
to him who is on his deathbed
but the narration is inauthentic and any
portion of the quran that is recited
is preferable as we mentioned
likewise
[Silence]
that anybody who goes to visit the ill
that he should
remind the person and when a person dies
a person should not respond by wailing
or ripping their clothing or screaming
or any of these things which
are impermissible and
go against what we know to be the
principles of patience
and perseverance in the face of
adversity
inshallah
me